alright guys it's time to talk about
valor --nt it's time to talk about the
game itself about the games twitch
numbers about the pros about the
cheaters about the eSports scene and
about what it's going to do to csgo is
valor n't going to kill counter-strike
alright guys before we get on with the
video proper you already know what i'm
going to tell you subscribe to the score
eSports YouTube channel based on what
you subscribe for we can give you more
the content you want so if you want more
csgo if you want more valor and sub to
the channel like this video and comment
below we do watch these things now let's
get back to talking about Valerie I've
had the beta key for about a week now
the game is good it's been fun playing
but I'm not here to review it I'm not a
game developer and I'm not an ex see s
go pro all I do know is that as much as
I enjoyed it after a few hours all I
wanted to do was load up csgo and Q
cache I'm smoking heavy I can flash you
:
don't eat don't plant but it doesn't
really matter if I want to play a
Valerie or csgo what matters is that
this game that is only in closed beta is
the only thing anyone is talking about
it's breaking twitch records it's
catapulting guys like summit 1g2
viewership he has never had before
and look an organized eSports scene
isn't that far away either the game
officially drops in summer and according
to a report from eSports observer Riot
Games is already secretly meeting with
certain eSports orgs presumably to get
them to join the inaugural Valerie
leagues now all this hype all this talk
has certain people a little worried
worried that Valerie isn't just a week
one twitch flash-in-the-pan
worried that this game could finally be
the one to dethrone counter-strike as
the world's premier hardcore FPS look
guys let's be honest it's been clear
that Riot Games has been gunning for not
only eSports but csgo
from the very start when riot was first
advertising this game they started off
by talking up a bunch of issues that are
important to hardcore FPS players like
server tick rates or the cheater problem
or gameplay emphasis on shooting people
in the head and I've noticed that some
people are getting a little emotional
about this they're getting a little
defensive as if they feel that that
Lauren is muscling in on something that
they've been in love with for in some
cases decades and that's counter strike
as if valor --nt is gonna kill
counter-strike honestly guys this is not
the time to be drawing battle lines I'm
just gonna come out and say it
valor --nt is not going to kill
counter-strike it's not gonna happen
counter-strike has never been in its
entire existence more popular than it is
right now it's constantly breaking its
own concurrent player records on Steam
and it's just absurd to think that when
valor --an leaves beta and goes live
we're gonna see this mass exodus of
players and pros from CS to valor it as
if your favorite CS pro over night is
going to become your favorite valor in
pro I mean think about it
League of Legends and dota coexist just
fine
and they're at least as similar as csgo
and valor n't in fact those two games
and make each other better and that's
exactly what's gonna happen here finally
we have some legitimate competition in
the hardcore FPS genre competition is
good for business and it's good for us
hell if you ask certain people this is
already lit a fire under valves ass to
improve their eight-year-old game sg553
reduced rate of fire and accuracy to
bring their weapons value to be more in
line with other rifles so here's a
question how long how long is the cig
bin [ __ ] okay and you tell me three
days after valent comes out we're [ __ ]
haulin ass now all of a sudden huh we're
just we're just kicking it into high
gear and fixing something we hated
forever okay alright yeah I see you no
one's falling for it right now brother
okay hey who knows if valve really
starts getting motivated maybe we'll get
that source to port the other thing that
everybody's talking about is who's gonna
play this thing at a pro level I mean
this game barely exists and already Brax
and AZK are signed to t1 an organization
that is a dynasty when it comes to
League of Legends and now they're
playing with shroud skadoodle and hiko
in some 100 Thieves Invitational for
valor n't with twists and a leash on the
other side with summit 1g she is crazy I
mean it feels like teams are signing
valor and pros left right and center now
and as crazy as it feels honestly guys
this is pure day one kind of [ __ ]
everyone else from cloud 9 here and
today I want to be officially announcing
that I will be pursuing Valerie over a
counter streaming of what I'm about to
say I mean with the utmost respect
guys like Kiko and swag and AZK are sick
competitors some of them are gods in
historical counter-strike but they're
not going to be the upper echelon of
valorem players at least riot better
hope they're not look when League of
Legends came out heroes of newerth and
dota players were good until they
weren't when overwatch was new guys like
AZ k did play but they're not the ones
in the overwatch League that we're
making story of videos
that Riot Games has to hope that there's
a generation of 15 year olds out there
right now who would slap the names I
just mentioned in a valiant Pro server
in a couple of years because these kids
won't be csgo transplants to valor n't
they'll be valiant endemic i mean look
in a series of games between Balor and
devs and ex-pro and streamer FPS players
including shroud by the way the devs
smoked the FPS players that's like a
quick little example of how important
like coordination of cops are you know
playing like knowing what the [ __ ]
you're doing we're just trying to out a
man just like solo play it's not gonna
work in this game it's not yes some of
those devs like volcano rx pros
themselves but you know what this tells
me it tells me we are putting way too
much emphasis on transferrable csgo
mechanics when it comes to this game the
streamer team was all great players they
know how to click on heads but they
didn't win why because they didn't have
the in-depth gain knowledge the devs had
they couldn't use their abilities the
way the devs did in other words this
game isn't just csgo re skinned may feel
like that right now but we're in closed
beta guys when this thing really gets
off the ground when we get into close
professional leagues we're gonna have to
re-evaluate how we view this game and i
think the people who we thought we're
gonna be good at it might not be as good
at it anymore
so while we've seen a few people who
have been out of the csgo scene for a
little bit say they're gonna go pro and
valor n't I wouldn't necessarily hold my
breath and I mean obviously when things
really get going it's nothing game devs
you have to worry about think about this
what if this game goes truly
international csgo surely is King and
North America in Europe big presence in
South America obviously CIA s region but
when was the last time you heard about a
Chinese team that wasn't tyloo hell when
was the last time you actually talked
about tyloo is it that China and Korea
are bad at shooters no it's because the
damn game wasn't even released in China
until 2017 it's because their closest
matchmaking
server was in Singapore that Korea
doesn't have enough young talent coming
up or enough veteran pros to mentor them
that they don't have a Korean language
hltv equivalent that games like
counter-strike online and crossfire took
over popularity in Asia when we were
playing source and csgo that China has a
censorship problem when it comes to
hardcore FPS games I could go on but
with valor n't
start for the Asian market valor and
Sprite cartoony graphics can help get
around that censorship problem in China
and with League of Legends installed in
every PC in every PC bong from Seoul to
Busan Riot Games already has their
distribution network set up and with the
rumors that Riot Games is developing a
launcher with all their games on it all
they got to do is go to all these PC
bongs and say hey you got legal legends
on your computer well now you have valor
into the Asian market is a big one and
Riot Games is already well practiced at
penetrating it all I'm saying is we
could be looking at a truly global
shooter here now the latest thing I've
heard people get agitated about when it
comes to valor --nt is the anti cheat
program called Vanguard apparently this
thing runs on your PC upon startup
whether you're playing the game or not
and some people are concerned about
privacy others say it's even causing
them to drop frames in other games for
their part Riot Games responded on
reddit saying that Vanguard takes up
minimal memory that it doesn't send or
receive any sensitive information to and
from your PC and that you can get rid of
it at any time now right from the get-go
Riot Games did promise us a pretty
robust anti cheat program so I guess it
stands to reason that it's a little
intrusive but I would like more research
done on this now that being said unlike
day 2 or something like that of the
closed beta there were cheaters not that
I blame riot for that I mean you guys
got to understand there are people out
there charging thousands of dollars for
cheap programs if people are willing to
put that much time and that much money
into being fake good at a game well it's
gonna happen anti cheat or not bottom
line here guys is that valor at being
good or being popular is not necessarily
a bad thing for csgo at all
fact it's probably almost certainly a
good thing from the gameplay perspective
valve is gonna be incentivized to
improve their game and hopefully that's
going to improve our pro scene as well
so hopefully we arrive at a place in a
couple years where both Valerie and csgo
can not only survive together but thrive
together I'm smoking heavy I can flash
you calling your plant coupon don't need
it